rose et miguel hello bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france on le
disait donc le parti d'antonio costard à
remporter ces législatives
cette victoire est ce qu elle était
attendue réellement ou pas
franchement je pense que non et je pense
qu'anthony costa lui même il à rester
une ligne était pas un
pont c'est qu'il avait gagné les
élections avec une majorité absolue
franchement je pense que non mais c'est
mais c'est un clair signal signal de que
les portugais on était six années en
arrière on
aimait des
dépositions et la posture du parti
socialiste dans le gouvernement des pays
mais pas avec la l'extrême-gauche et pas
avec les communistes
alors c'était un clair signal de que les
partis qui veut les socialistes mais je
pense que non entendu que cela n'était
pas entendre ce résultat alors les
grands perdants finalement sont les
partis de la gauche radicale oui
totalement 2 les deux les communistes
ont perdu la moitié de ses députés et
après l'extrême gauche a perdu de passer
de 19 députés pour quatre deux députés
alors je pense qu'ils sont les grands
perdants de ces élections est un clair
signal de que les portugais la majorité
des votants portugais on a dit on
on est en train de vivre dans une dans
une crise politique et la crise
politique c'est à cause de vous et c'est
à cause de vous qu'on n'a pas un budget
pour cette année alors on va pénaliser
les deux parties et cette éclaircie nal
de que les portugais
sont de gauche les bons moments et veut
que la gauche que le centre gauche
récente fronde du gouvernement mais pas
avec la gauche radicale alors il ya donc
une crise politique politique vous
lisiez il ya eu cette crise politique au
portugal il est aussi une crise
sanitaire dans le monde entier est ce
que la gestion d'antonio costa du
gouvernement de cette crise sanitaire et
bien elle a été aussi saluée par la
population qui a souhaité renouveler un
sens son adhésion au parti socialiste
oui je pense que oui je pense que oui je
pense que le parti socialiste à mon avis
je pense que le parti socialiste a fait
l'un une gestion de la pandémie de la
crise sanitaire bien fait alors les
numéros sont et hébron portugal a
commencé très mal la crise mais la fiche
sanitaire mais en ce moment la plupart
de la voix de la population est vaccinée
les entreprises sont en train de sont en
train de fonctionner la vie du séjour du
portugais se mentent se
retourner avec
normalité on peut dire on peut dire
comme ça et de l'est plus grand parti de
l'opposition le social démocrate dans le
ministe de la crise pandémique ils ont
adopté une posture de travailler en
avait que les socialistes et pas de
faire une opposition dont dans le
parlement alors ils ont travaillé dans
une équipe mais je pense que oui mais je
pense que la crise sanitaire a été bien
réglée par les socialistes autre fait
majeur de ce scrutin c'est la montée de
la droite radicale
7,15 % de deux voix comment est-ce que
vous expliquer cette montée aujourd'hui
et l'entrée de la droite radicale ou au
parlement portugais
ça c'est aussi ça c'est ça c'est un des
raisons de la majorité absolue tous des
socialistes parce que je pense que c'est
aussi une autre finale que les portugais
sont tellement
fatigués de la droite traditionnelle de
la droite très conservateur et d'une
droite qui n'a pas finaud position très
claire et très est très
raide et d'en contrôler les socialistes
et sa sainte claire finale de qu'il y a
encore
des voteurs de droite et je pense que il
ya un parti fois il faut le dire de le
céder est-ce que cela le traditionnel
parti de centre droite portugais par la
première fois dans un canton il n'a pas
et n'a pas lé géant députés et des
voteurs de droite je pense qu'ils ont
voté dont le séga
clercine halde que la droite
traditionnelle est fatigué il a besoin
d'être un nouveau discours avec de
nouveaux personnages et un discours
actuel dans dans dans l'année comme
convient enfin indices kurdes à 20 ans
en arrière et apprécie aussi un clercine
halde que des voteurs de droite sont
fatigués de
2,2 les conditions économiques que sévit
au portugal 2 du chômage au portugal
portugal si les puces et les pays avec
les plus taxes de l'europe les prix de
l'essence toutes les semaines augmente
et je pense que ça s'est éclairci naldo
qui lie à votr de droite au portugal
mais qu'ils sont fatigués de la droite
traditionnelle et elles ont pénalisé les
sociaux-démocrates et les centres
le centre social et sega a obtenu avec
un discours très populiste mais qui est
un discours populiste mais un discours
facile et un disque eurent quelques les
voteurs scientifique et c est ce qu un
discours qui remet aussi en cause la
politique de bruxelles ou pas forcément
comme ci comme ça à 50 secondes le séga
c'est un parti européiste mais en même
temps il n'aime pas ce
ce modèle européen de l'actualité alors
c'est un petit peu toutes les positions
de ces gars sont un petit peu on le
comprend mois marc franchement je ne
comprends pas parce que j'ai lit le
gélis dans son plan pour ces poussées
élections et alors franchement il dit un
truc pour de tout et de rien alors il
dit il faut qu'on donne des conditions
le service national de santé mais après
ils ne disent pas comme ça alors c'est
une surface il populiste hic est que les
gens tendre et comprend et construit il
faut qu'on donne les meilleures
conditions à liestal et police il faut
qu'on défende notre nation il faut qu'on
espère entrer des migrants paix parce
qu'ils sont en train de de rester avec
notre job mais après il ne dit pas
comment alors c'est ainsi c'est un parti
de tout et de rien merci beaucoup en
tout cas aux emmy loin de lelo d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
ancien secrétaire général du parti de
droite portugaise